à tous wishing you love happiness de
best of je vous souhaite de l'amour du
bonheur et surtout beaucoup de santé je
vous aime à bientôt bye bye
je teste le coiffeur le plus bizarre
je suis choqué
enfin ses reposants j'ai rien dit
[Musique]
il était mon âme
quand je suis passé là-bas je pensais
pas que c'était à ce point-là
voilà voilà
ah bah là c'est
je sais pas comment je vais faire du
coup là
aussi oui parce que j'ai essayé de
reculer sur ce bordel opération
sauvetage réussie voilà j'ai réussi à
dégager le coffre de toit
et maintenant je sais pas quoi faire
[Musique]
du ciel avec tes jouets famille
n'oublie pas nos petits souliers
mais avant de partir
il faut prendre de te couvrir
[Musique]
à cause de toi